on the recent writings on that
meditation that you posted
uh where the discussion is going into a
desire and
um but along with that you'd also
mentioned
um
intention and also you know desire and
wanting to succeed at something and
trying and that how that is also
embedded within the ego trite part-time
mind and
um and I have felt at times in my
training where
um words
where it is more of the being that I
don't feel that but there's also been
times
where I'm trying to
press or want to be you know want to do
something right or
to be
um
want something and um and in those cases
I've realized it's also when I'm
suffering from other ego type part-time
maladies
however when
I'm in those States it seems like it's
really difficult to dissolve that so
even when we talk about
releasing and I remember there's been
times where you have just said
you need to release all your desire you
need to all of your desire all of your
desire and just like
that just seems so Monumental and it
just seems well there's that's
everything this is really and so if you
can speak on how um
what we can do in you know in those
times to help I don't know like I said
dissolve I feel is like the best because
we're holding on or I'm holding on to
all right and so
remember so the the question
[Music]
it was actually another
um
patreon subscriber actually asks the
same exact question
um and it's one that you have to first
understand
the question itself is produced by the
ego tripartite mine do you see because
the question
if you look at the question
underneath it you're going to see a
dichotomous framework
you're going to see the self right and
um
what's happening is
that you
you kind of I call it a language game it
turns into a language game that your
mind your intellect in particular which
is the ego tripart type mind
um is trying to figure out how to solve
this uh Transcendence of dichotomy and
it cannot do it okay and hence my phrase
which is the the mind which by which I
mean the ego tripartite mind so the my
phrase that I usually say is the Mind
cannot cure itself
so if you want to spell it out the ego
tripartite mind cannot stop being the
ego tripartite mind
and the question arises from that and in
that question you're actually seeing the
ego tripartite mind
reefine itself in continuing its
functioning because all it deduces is
this makes no sense
reducing
so
this
lack of
um Solutions because the ego tripartite
minorities doesn't see the solution this
is lack of solutions and this reduction
to solving only with the ego tripartite
mind is really a product of modernity
now it was always if you look
historically you're going to see caveats
against this which tells you that it's
really a human thing and people have
always made this mistake otherwise
pre-modern cultures would not have a
caveat warning you about this mistake do
you see that but it's so prevalent today
as modernity itself as as modern culture
itself is a product of ego tripartite
mind running rampant and unchecked you
see we're really doomed to this kind of
thing
um
um because there's few there's very very
few people who actually
know how to get out of this
see there's very few people around okay
there were always few people around but
it's now like you're looking for the
chupacabra or something you know
you know it's like or Bigfoot you know
it's like that that rare okay
um and but what pre-modern cultures did
is they understood One debt to eat what
I call the egotype Prototype mine is
only one aspect of your being
and so training
has to involve other aspects of your
being okay now we're in budo and we're
in Aikido and so we're looking really at
Silk Road culture Technologies of self
got it how did they solve for this okay
is what I'm going to show you and it's
you're gonna know oh yeah I forgot about
all that other stuff okay but you're
gonna see but there's people out there
that don't know this stuff okay but I'm
telling you as a historian of religion
it's in every single other
um what I would call Mystical tradition
okay every single religion solve for
that problem and they did it in the the
very same way okay and the first premise
is you are not only that mind
okay and what they did by default was is
to tell you that mind is not only not
all of you but that is a lesser you do
you see or some aspect of you that you
you want to rise above so it's a lower
you do you understand that so for
example in uh judeo-christian Traditions
there was you but there was your soul
and your soul had some sort of agency
and Consciousness to it uh that was
outside of that everyday Virginia sense
itself do you see and you weren't
entirely in control or in possession of
that soul that thing that aspect of you
didn't really belong to you do you see
that so there's a there was a part of
you that was not
that part
okay and that part of you that was not
that part is a greater you is it true or
you is what you're supposed to aim for
okay in Silk Road cultures
um
uh you had you had three parts of you
okay so we would say you would have your
uh and and we can core and this
corresponds to your training methodology
okay so you have your physical part and
in the physical part is that material
part and is that ego tripartite part
okay and then you have uh what I call
the energetic part but sometimes I call
it your alchemical part okay
and then you have your spirit part
now you have to be careful
um
because these are modern words and
they're I use modern words so you as
modern people understand them okay but I
understand these in the pre-modern sense
okay so when we talk about your physical
self we're not just talking about your
body because we cannot separate your
body from that ego tripartite mind
because we cannot separate your
experience of the body from that mind
okay and this is how in Silk Road
cultures you would have like the yoga
charter school which would say
everything is mine or in modern
philosophical schools you have idealism
okay so I I am never able to separate
my experience of something from the
thing that I am experiencing something
through so when we talk about physical
this is what when I refer to your body
mind
okay your body mind
you always think of that you never
you're never that mind like modern
psychology or modern Neuroscience do you
see you're always your body your
experience of your body I can't get away
I they're together okay and then when we
talk about energy alchemical
we're not talking about
your electricity
uh we're not talking about nerve endings
or anything like that do you understand
this is you're you're not anything here
you're not anything that secular
materialism could validate
um or cease to validate okay so you're
you're really looking sometimes you'll
you'll see so I saw a video by uh Domo
today and he likes to say you're you're
subtle your subtle aspects
[Music]
what does that mean right okay what you
have to understand is once we get to
these and here's where that historian of
a religion comes in once you get to
these Concepts these are really Apple
what are called apophatic Concepts okay
they're negative Concepts okay so the
way to understand what this is is to say
it's not that
and it's not that and it's how it's just
how it is okay
um
if you look for example
you you let's say you go to the Buddhist
concept of no self
you see how it has the no and self it's
an apple apoptic concept shunyata
Emptiness is is also an epiphatic
concept so pre-modern cultures are
really running
not too irrationality but pushing
rational thinking to its limit where the
only way that a positive thing can be
said is that some negative thing has to
stand in contrast to it it's an
extension in Silk Road culture it's an
extension of Yin Yang Theory okay so for
example if you go to Taoism
um they have it's it is uh the hole in
the wagon wheel
that makes it useful it's not the wheel
itself it's the emptiness in the hole
that allows the axle to go in there do
you see
um and so while empty and while not
material is actually if there was no
empty space for it then the axle could
not function do you see or The Emptiness
in the cup is what actually creates the
cup not the Cup itself do you see that
so you have that Dallas concept going
okay well the same thing is going on in
you now if you want to say that the
emptiness in the cup or the hole in the
wagon wheel is a subtler part to the
wheel I'm not sure that is solving the
problem that domo's trying to solve
but he's trying to say that
there is a concreteness or there is
let's say this
that emptiness in the cup is as real as
the Cup itself do see that so when he's
trying to say that it's subtle he does
he's trying to say that there's some
substance to it but it's not this
substance that's so gross
do you understand that okay
I get what he's saying I've heard that
that variant of expression you can see
it throughout history they're trying to
do that but you could see that for
example if you say
um
there's young energy
and it's subtle all you will try to do
as a practitioner is try to really feel
it you know what I mean
so what with what with this
do you see that so it doesn't really
help in my opinion okay but it makes
sense I'm not saying it's wrong okay
these are apathetic Concepts so this is
not that and not this but this is not
that in that either okay or another way
of saying if you want to put it in
positive terms uh everything else that
is not this or that is this
okay
and I'll tell you why they reached that
conclusion because we're working
backwards
it looks like we're working forward in
understanding this but we're actually
working backwards okay because this is
not how it starts and sometimes when you
train you think that this is like a
linear progression do you see
just like shuhadi so you'll hear modern
modern aikidoka
will uh talk about this and they will
understand it materially of this level
and they understand it as a linear
progression you start with shoe then you
go to ha and then you go to we and that
is not how that Buddhist Theory works
okay this stuff happens concentrically
which means it's not linearly it's
simultaneously so if you're in your
being you are doing this simultaneously
uh in your training you don't go I'm
going to learn a form and then I'm going
to break the form and then I'm going to
reconcile form and non-form it either
happens all at once or it does not
happen ever okay so I have to do all
this at once what's happening to the
beginner is the beginner can only
function at this level okay and as I
said
if we're looking at this you're going to
think that it's a line and you're going
to think it goes this way better
Michelle I'm going to tell you that it
does not okay I'll just get there all
right so first let's move here this
energetic alchemical thing
is
um
there are
aspects of you
that are
not this the what are they
they are you inside of the larger Cosmic
order of things okay so for example
um
in Silk Road cultures uh the creation
act happened according to a natural
order of things okay and that process
which you've heard me refer to as the
Genesis act the Genesis Act is happening
in you on a regular basis over and over
and over again okay uh what does that
mean so we'll stick to the Taoist
tradition uh the Dow is in you and the
Dao is constantly materializing into yin
and yang aspects of you but you can
reverse that such that you reconcile the
yin and yang aspects in you and you'll
come to the undone stage or the Dao
stage or the pre-genesis stage okay
you're looking at a cosmological Act of
moving from nothingness to somethingness
well you can reverse that act and you're
going to go from somethingness back to
nothingness okay or in judeo-christian
uh you got your ass kicked out of the
garden do you see and because you
learned about uh the knowledge uh that
you had you ate of the tree of knowledge
and so you had dichotomous thinking
right good and bad good and evil right
and wrong to all this all dichotomous
thought and you had your identity in
there you had you have your fear and
your Will To Power and what you're
supposed to do is undo all that and get
back into the garden who's in the garden
God's in the garden do you see now
you're chilling out with God or take it
outside of the narrative you are in
communion with the Divine so communion
with the Divine one with the Tao loss of
self same exact thing okay
so
what these Silk Road cultures did is
they said hey uh you can actually
tap into that natural order of things
that Genesis act and you can start to
use that
tapping in
to change
this part of you
okay and
to develop this part of you okay so this
this part here and I'll get I know that
sounds abstract to you this part here is
a necessary middle ground that modern
religion has done away with
we we don't know this stuff anymore okay
[Music]
um
and so when you look at modern religion
you have like okay I'm Gonna Get You
know or Wellness systems I'm gonna get
really fit and I'm gonna go into therapy
and I'm gonna have a therapist and then
I'm gonna be fine do you see that and uh
well let's let's track for that
yeah let's track for that
no one ever gets out of therapy everyone
gets on medication and more medication
and more medication it doesn't look like
it's yielding results do you see do you
get it and we'd normalize
self-medication so alcohol
um at-risk behaviors and things like
that do you see and we normalize numbing
ourselves to the environment because the
environment is so stressful do you see
all this it's not working okay because
the mind cannot cure the mind
okay
and then we have this sense of spirit
but our modern sense of spirit is so
abstract
it is so abstract
that you're only filled with doubt and
it never goes away
and it doesn't hold
when the hits the fan
it holds under ideal conditions okay
and it's kind of philosophical
which is this do you see so take for
modern day vedanta I told you if you
listen to the New York vedanta
instructor he's basically just using
this mind and he's trying to reach a
rational understanding and everyone is
convinced apparently I will understand
uh
vedantas to such a degree that I'll
finally stop suffering do you see and oh
I'm still suffering I must not
understand it to the degree necessary do
you see this is so in Buddhist
terms I'm going to philosophically be
able to out argue anybody on the
doctrine of no self and emptiness do you
see
well I'm supposed to be suffering free
but I'm not I oh I must not realize it
enough do you see that's what they're
doing okay
why do we do this and why do we have
this abstract Airy intangible thing that
has no Integrity no viability under
stress
is we don't have this anymore
and in this dojo we do have this and in
Silk Road cultures you did have this and
also in judeo-christian Traditions you
did have this again so for example the
word alchemical is Not Silk Road culture
uh terminology this is judeo-christian
terminology do you understand that so
when you hear for example uh uh when
damo's saying inner Alchemy like that's
not Chinese
do you understand this this is how how
chemical investigations and studies they
go way back in their middle eastern
moving into Europe
okay got caught that
um
it's not it's not the word that
is in in in
um in Silk Road cultures
it's not pre-chemistry
do you do you understand that that's not
they it it's a good translation of what
Silk Road cultures are doing but this is
an actual cultural practice from another
culture okay and it and but it's working
in the same way on the same things okay
so
since I can't stop my desire here
do you see
I can start working on this thing here
which is outside of this
do you see I can work on myself
alchemically or energetically to start
gaining moments of cessation of this
mind
okay
now I'm telling you we're working
backwards
this is my experience okay
I can only talk about my experience and
but my experience here is my personal
experience and my research experience
okay
in my research experience and my
personal experiences this happens first
at some point
you become primed I don't know how or
why
in in
subcontinent Indian tradition they they
would say your karma got you there
okay and now I want you to understand
Karma philosophically what it means is I
don't know why
there are so many countless lifetimes
and cause and effects that they're
incalcable but they must have fell in
place because there is a long cause and
effect they must have fell in place and
you were primed to have a glimmer or a
moment where this mind stopped on its
own
now that might sound weird to you but
not to a pre-modern person that has to
be possible
the ego try part-time mind must be able
to stop do you see that otherwise
there's no point in this
it must be an aspect of the ego
tripartite mind in other words
and that
potential to stop
erupts it just does it just does
why Karma okay
so at some point you will have a glimmer
of its cessation now that might sound
super weird and rare but think about it
it is nothing more than a uh a
Reconciliation this is so put in modern
terms modern philosophical terms it is a
Reconciliation of the subject object
dichotomy that is how to understand the
ecstatic experience so let's you
probably that word will be more
understood understandable to you and
it's static experience have you ever
in your life
had a sense of a loss of self
I bet you did
it happens all the time in just normal
lives
you see nature
you're a first kiss your first love
you dance the whole night away it could
be chemically induced do you understand
do you guys get that okay
for some people it just hits them
there's no that it just comes out of
nowhere okay
and then you have all these kind of
things where I don't know Crow went by
oh come on and the dude had the
experience right or Brad Warner said he
was on that bridge and it just happened
to him do you see
just like I mentioned the soul is not in
your possession nor in your control
these eruptions of the cessation of the
ego tripartite mind are not in your
control they just happen
that is actually what happens first
and from there you can start to build
this in my experience
you you don't go this way
you get your eruptions
and then you go oh
I can actually gain some awareness or
some
some mind experience of this happening
okay
you have this
you have a feeling let's use that word I
use that word a lot you have this you
had an experience
you felt the experience do do you
understand you did you didn't cause it
you didn't intend to have it you didn't
realize it you didn't reach the pen
ultimate intellectual understanding of
some complex philosophy
it happened to you
so it had a feeling of it you had some
sense of it do you see that feeling is
what you're doing here
and in my experience this training
brings an agency to that feeling
meaning
whereas initially it may have erupted
out in my feeling in my experience
Beyond My Control through this training
I can actually bring an agency to it I
can make it happen again and I can keep
it happening as long as I want and I can
continue to to have it again regardless
of the environment that I'm in okay and
this is what I mean when I say this
actually happens the other way and as
somebody that is first exposed to this
this comes first
then you get this you bring some agency
to this do you understand do you get
that okay but when you pay attention
remember I said it happens
simultaneously concentrically it does it
does it happens concentrically
simultaneously but in terms of training
this will happen and then this develops
agency in it
and that allows you to have this
manifest itself simultaneously as
whatever you're doing okay and so
this part
is not this mine
okay
this part here
is not the mind that is even capable of
Desiring
this part here is a part of you this is
in you that's why you can do this
training that's why you can have this
experience the soul is a part of you
see
you can have an experience of soul
it's not you causing it it's happening
to you you didn't generate the feeling
you're just feeling it as it's happening
to you so when you're doing this
training you're not doing this
and you are because you have to be
in a desirable state
so your question is how do I how do I
stop my desires that is this question
from here do you see what you do instead
is you do this training you do this
training this training is not that mind
this training is that other part of you
which I call the god of mine okay this
part is what I call when this mind stops
okay so what you are learning is
how to stop that mind here it happened
to you
here you're bringing agency to the
cessation of that mind do you see that
now when you go
I am Desiring to stop the mind oh that's
not mine don't do that instead
let the yin let the young aspect into
your body
do you see let it in don't make it come
in don't want it to come in get out of
the way it will come in this is the
natural workings of the universe you're
obstructing it from coming into you
so for example
the person comes the person pushes in
kilon Wausau right they're tasked with
spinal displacement right everyone got
that and then you go I'm going to let
the young aspect in well that is when
you do all of the things that you know
you're not supposed to do you stop them
from coming in that's a desire do you
see and when you stop them from coming
in you tense up do you see and when you
tense up you're blocking the young
aspect from coming in and you start to
adopt bracing angles and external
engines and you're doing all this kind
of stuff do you get that so
if we take the judeo-christian
they're like God damn it
I can't freaking do it
there is something here
that you need
and that is faith
faith is not belief
okay that that's how we understand it
now Faith is a skill do you see
do you get it faith is the skill that I
in modern terms have called release
do you get that so
that thing is coming in
and you're like uh
I'm pushing on my I I feel it in my
shoulder I feel it in my bicep I can't
let it come in
you could answer it from my modern terms
which is uh you're not releasing enough
you don't have faith
okay you don't have skills yet at
disappearing
as letting go
of releasing
of
Trust
okay now think about this for example
how many times have you seen it how many
times have you felt it
do you see if you have somebody right
there that you can touch that can do
that thing that you're being asked to do
do you understand that
but
it's not enough
okay which is why I'm telling you this
does not mean belief
okay
if you understand faith and the skill of
release
as a skill as a necessary skill
then you have to do the work that
develops the skill
you cannot go I just want to stop
Desiring
I want I desire to stop Desiring it
doesn't work do you see you have to do
the work that develops the skill
okay
so
this is where all those practices come
in
and why all of those practices actually
function
to
in a way
contest the self
okay so we're going to take this part
here and we're going to take the other
word we're going to use another
tradition and we're going to call that
the self
like the Buddhist tradition itself okay
all of your practices work
where you cannot
keep the self
how so
the four disciplines
you you cannot stay the same and
practice the four disciplines
Faithfully religiously in modern terms
do you get it with 100 devotion
if you pay attention
yeah yeah right if we were graded on a
curve you're probably like 50 do you you
know what I mean okay 50 in modern terms
that's the f
right okay
um
daily training
right or daily training at the training
equations
four to six hours you cannot remain the
same
and train every day four to six hours
you cannot so if you hold that and I
think I wrote about this recently the
reason you hold that is precisely
because just like a young energy the
monastic code so to speak
is a kind of young energy are you going
to contest it
or are you going to yield to it
do you see
um the all the dojo etiquette you got to
get rid of yourself to take do it all at
all times do you see
I mean how many times
you think yes Sensei is easy as a
response but how many times do you hear
training
the answer is yes and say you see and
then it can't just be verbal can
virtual yielding do you see let go man
um
you also have the practice of servitude
how much do we actually do that
and when and with whom
do you see do we only do it with
strangers when we had that talk before
right it's easy to serve strangers but
man serving my spouse who's a total
do you know what I mean like
now out you know what I mean or
the kids right after we talked about the
kids uh where we want to be on high and
Shout Out orders at the kids and have
them as opposed to what what work do I
need to do to help this child what what
physical effort and exhaustion rate do I
have to produce in myself to assist this
child do you see that's different okay
and then you broaden that out right such
as my my work practice is yes you
someone asked me yes you see someone at
work asked me the answer is yes it's
just yes and then you go do the work
right do you guys understand that okay
now
it's easy to try at first for a while
you're like I'm gonna be the person at
work that always says yes do you see
and so for a while you're like okay good
I feel good about myself
and they're gonna but what you need to
do is keep doing it you need to keep
doing it so that you realize
I'm never going to be recognized
and a lot of these people hate me
precisely because I say yes
and you keep saying yes and you keep
saying yes okay
it's kind of like zazen almost anybody
can sit still for like 30 seconds or two
minutes do you see that you gotta sit
there until this mind is screaming get
the up and start singing the stones
you know what I mean and then keep going
and keep going okay these are all
practices that trigger the self
and if you pay attention
there's a part of you that does know
that because we don't follow them the
way we're supposed to follow them
so when you look at nageuke it's just a
microcosm of that very process there is
a way to do the kilo nozza do you see
but that way requires that this has to
be let go
okay so for example
you desire the throw right we a lot of
that was stop stop trying to oh there's
the head throw the head
do you see that just do this
and let the throw be an incidental
consequence a coincidence of this do you
see do you guys get that
or um
you're doing we're doing the sparring
class and how many techniques were you
trying to do do you see no no no just do
this
and the techniques will reveal
themselves
this I here
the service I
or this idea or or the philosophy or the
or the the the
technological science behind all of
these monastic
training
is really just
yoga
so and I mentioned this because this is
the most clearest example of of how and
why these monastic codes work okay
it's karma yoga so you go back to the
bhagavad-gita right and they're like
dude you're a prince and you're a
warrior you're gonna kill some
that's your job do you see that but
you're not going to be attached to the
fruits of the labor so I'm gonna do
the cosmological order of things do you
see that without going there's the head
he didn't even knock it bitched do you
get what I'm saying I just do this
do you guys understand that and so in
that moment when you could throw the
head but you just do this
you practicing release
you see that and the moment when um you
veered the four disciplines or you Veer
in your service or when you feel that
I'm saying yes so that people like me
and I get appreciated and I get the
recognition
do you see that's your opportunity to
keep doing it without it
okay and it's a skill
switch means how long do you do this for
your whole life do you see it's not a
state it's a skill you do it all all day
long every day and then you die
okay that's how it works
your idea of there being a state is a
desire you're like I want to finally
stop
because this is exhausting
do you see no keep going okay
this sense of exhaustion
and this keep going you see
is and and tobun is going to actually
refer to it with Saint John's
terminology
this is The Dark Knight
you see when when this mind
is being attacked by practices that do
not reify the self
but deconstruct a self
to develop this skill this mind will
feel attacked
it'll feel lost depressed it will Rebel
do you see but you keep going
that's the Dark Knight and in every
single so here we have a modern Zen Monk
using the phrase The Dark Knight you see
that monk kobun his father was a Zen
priest he went to a Buddhist University
he trained under some uh
um trained under kodo who is probably
the last great
then
Herman
okay
and he's using Saint John's phrases
because it's in Zen too
you're going to hit this moment
where it'll just feel like this is not
working this is lost I should stop do
you get it
but now you keep going
you keep going okay
so this mind can never stop Desiring
but these practices these aspects of you
are outside of that mind
so these practices are outside of your
desire in fact when you desire these
you're just back here
so you're when I say just rock
the spiral rotation of your tongue did
you see you that's a choice you could do
that
or you could go I'm gonna do it even
I'll get on them
you see that and when you just go with
the spiral rotation of the Tom Dan
you're in that feeling
it's just a feeling you keep this
feeling keep it keep it keep it keep the
feeling
the technique will reveal itself
not you
it just happens why that's how the
cosmos works
it's just how it works
well that's convenient yeah it is
but it's how it works so all things that
work that's convenient okay
so and the reason you go well that seems
like a circular argument and I don't
really get it again that's this
the reason pre-modern cultures landed on
this is because it started here whoa
whoa what the just happened
do you understand you're not gonna go oh
nothing
do you see that this this mind goes
nothing nothing that doesn't want you to
do that that's why this
culturally historically this side is
demonic meaning this side is
antithetical to this do you see
so it's gonna go no no no no no no that
does not exist
don't go looking don't be there don't
you feel like yeah
do you see that but people that do this
usually get something like this
there's some context for those
spontaneous ecstatic moments right so
for example I don't know I used to be a
dancer ever dance all night ever dance
on you like Lou I've had I've had those
man this is the best nights around man
yeah
you know what I'm talking about there's
no context for it
you just go well that was fun
stop looking
instead of you going like where did holy
cow I lost track of time
you see but other cultures had context
for it
and your budo training gives you context
for it so you have had moments as you
said where you're out here and the
things just work
do you get it right I've seen you do
that hey that's exactly it stop doing
that other thing
just let it happen and you get you you I
don't know what it's just the
Recollections usually like your last
three or four reps and then because I
usually call it like that now because
you're gonna go back to do the other
thing you've heard me say let's say I'm
not on a positive note you see because
it erupts you had it you had it
do you get it
okay so there's a context for it and now
you have to keep replicating the feeling
and then you bring agency to it okay
now most places don't have a context for
it
they do this they do the other thing oh
we had some alcohol and it was just
great music to see they're gonna look at
it not as what happened to my mind and
the sense of time and the loss of self
there's no context for it and so they
don't look for it they don't recognize
what happened you see they don't have a
technique that just revealed itself
and it gets worse because you have a
choreographed UK
there's
it's not the technique revealed itself
okay made it happen
do you see and so that okay that's
choreographed
is can never ever give you this stuff
the choreographed you get is this
corruption here the ego tripartite mine
has taken over contemporary Aikido
that's what everyone does do you see and
the art now becomes at best symbolic or
metaphorical that's all it is do you see
so let's combine this with uh the other
patreon thread on tisier's
IDI aminage okay I don't know if you saw
it but
you guys should have noticed
that UK is not falling when the young
hand comes do you see the the young hand
that young hand does not have the power
to throw anybody
except someone that it could physically
overpower do you see that because
still and then you push him over do you
get it
so you're how much you weigh Virginia
130 and how tall are you
you're never gonna push me over by doing
this on my head do you get it I don't
can you reach Chris how tall are you
Chris six two six two can you reach
Chris's head you know what I mean do you
get it and so what you're seeing is
a a mechanic an external mechanical
engine that appears to function
why is it function because UK is going
to do their flip for you do you see
and if Uka is doing their flip for you
that means ook is in control of
themselves
do you understand that uh and so UK is
not in kazushi
you see and so none of this stuff is is
functioning it just appears to function
and so all Luca has to do is is obey the
cue
you feel a little pressure here okay go
ahead turn inside my technique and throw
yourself over yourself
you get it
indeed basic that we have
this hand on the neck
does that's viral rotation remember and
so by the time this hand comes in UK is
already falling do you see and I am just
doing
the spiral rotation in the content
so I have this hand on the neck right so
I'm doing that and then I'm coming
around when I enter I'm doing it on the
other side of my body
and UK happens to fall okay
or tactically
ukia was already falling by the time the
young hand came in
which is the only way I can reconcile
this yin and yang right if you can stand
it still that's yongyang ifuke is going
forward that's Yong Yan Uka has to be
going backwards for me to enter there's
no Yin space for me to ID me if it is
not already going backwards do you get
that and so that I'm reconciling this
I'm working at this level as opposed to
I kind of touch them
on his face turn inside and throw
yourself
okay
there is a way however if you don't want
to use this hand on the neck
to generate this same thing with one
with the lead hand
okay and you actually do it in
tensionage
so there's no reason why you can't do it
in IDI aminage either okay but it's not
his way okay what we have to do is
reproduce
the same effect that this hand was doing
with this hand
do you get it all right let's work on
that